hey David is it now time for Bernie or
Warren to drop out because Joe Biden is
still in the lead and we as progressives
need to take him out so listen I've
answered this a couple of times before
and it's been a few months so I'm glad
to address it again because we're
further into the Democratic primary at
this point what exactly would be the
point of Bernie or Warren dropping out
as the question is asked here the point
would be
we don't want Biden to win because he's
not a progressive Bernie and Warren are
the two progressives with the best shot
if one drops out it helps the other it
takes out Biden and then we laugh all
the way to the bank okay
the problem with this is the math of it
and the math of it is I reviewed earlier
today still doesn't really favor this
strategy you know I got a guy did a live
stream over the weekend on Twitch and I
got a phone call from someone who said
hey David you know I want I think it was
Bernie to win or something like that I
want Bernie to win but if Bernie doesn't
win Iowa should I maybe look at
switching my vote when I vote in New
York State the caller was in New York
State voter and I said guys that you
you're getting way ahead of yourselves
here you don't need to do anything like
that nothing is going to be there's one
way in which those first four primaries
Iowa New Hampshire Nevada and South
Carolina will really sort of quote
decide the winner which is if one person
sweeps all of them and does it really
handily like with overwhelming numbers
which is not likely to happen at this
point okay the most likely scenario is
that no matter what happens in those
first four primaries it's still going to
be a fight in two March third I think
March third is Super Tuesday there's
like 14 primaries on March 3rd
maybe Super Tuesday is actually a
different date but there's a huge chunk
of votes that are going to be coming
after those four primaries okay anyone
will all most likely be able to win
after those first for support who you
like if it's Bernie or Warren that's
totally fine because here's the math
about Bernie and Warren okay Warren
supporters have Bernie as their second
choice but only
by three points over Biden okay meaning
that for every hundred I believe I'm
going by the numbers I recall for every
hundred Warren supporters that change
their minds or if Warren bails go to
their second choice candidate for every
hundred I think twenty-eight go to
Bernie and 25 go to Biden okay that's
not enough for Bernie to close the gap
if Warren quits all right now let's look
at the other option Bernie quits Bernie
supporters now according to the latest
morning consult poll Bernie supporters
have Biden as their top choice by two
points over Warren I think it's like
twenty eight to twenty six so if Bernie
quits for every hundred of his
supporters that go to their second
choice
Biden builds a lead over Elizabeth
Warren okay
if either drops out they help each other
and Biden roughly equally so the math
doesn't support the strategy of Bernie
quitting to help Warren or Warren
quitting to help Bernie now you could
say well those might be the second
choices as of now but if one quits and
endorses the other then it'll shift
those numbers it may shift the numbers
to some degree but we're just talking
about the primaries here and it I
predict ssin is it would not shift it as
much as you imagine so let's just all go
out if you're an Iowa voter you're gonna
get the first crack at it go out and
vote whoever you actually support if
you're a New Hampshire voter and Iowa
doesn't go the way you want go out and
vote for whoever you actually support in
New Hampshire if one person wins Iowa
and another one's new wins New Hampshire
and then it's time for Nevada I believe
is the third primary go out and vote for
whoever you like in Nevada this is going
to sort itself out there is so much time
for consolidation in the Bernie Warren
supporter groups that these are not the
things we should be that we the the
candidates who are in the top three
should not drop out there's a whole
bunch of people at the bottom that need
to go because they've got no shot and
are just a distraction
on the stage but it is not time for
Bernie to drop out it is not time for
Warren to drop out why would someone in
the top three who is right in there
within a few points of being in the lead
of this thing drop out at this point in
time my suggestion is that we stop
talking about that and focus on the
important things like substantive
debates figuring out exactly how each
person will pay for their health care
plan and clearing the stage of some of
the hangers-on that have no chance
whatsoever of winning and are
contributing nothing other than giving
the people who have a shot time to sip
water as they wait for the next question
to come to them you disagree with me let
me know we've got a great bonus show for
you today two ways to get the bonus show
become a member at join pakman.com or
become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show